لكن كيف يتاثر المواطنون دعونا نلقي نظره
اقرب في اوروبا اولا استطلاعنا للراي
نتائجها جاءت صادمه
93% من الاوروبيين قليقون من ارتفاع كلفه
العيش وقدرتهم على الوفاء بالتزاماتهم
الماليه والنتيجه كما تشاهدون تظاهرات في
بريطانيا وفي فرنسا الملايين خرجوا الى
الشوارع هذا الاسبوع الاسباب كثيره اساسها
اقتصادي ومنها ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه ورفع
سن التقاعد كما حدث في فرنسا اليوم اما في
امريكا التخلف عن سداد الديون الذي حذرت
منه وزيره الخزانه سيؤدي الى ركودنا في
البلاد واسمع عالميه في العالم المواطن
الامريكي هنا سيارات تاثير تكاليف اقتراضه
سترتفع والكثير من الامريكيين سيقدون
وظائفهم في العالم العربي الاوضاع اكثر
صعوبه
والسكان تحت خط فقط
130 مليون شخص بلغه الارقام فيما يتوقع ان
يرتفع هذا الرقم في 2024
نسبه بطاله قياسيه التضخم خرج عن السيطره
دول عربيه كثيره مدينه لصندوق النقد
الدولي
مفيش حد اصلا بعيد عنها ولكن في امور ابسط
من كده بكثير كثيرات للناس لسه بتضخم انا
فعلا الشخصي دي ناتجه عن
الاستيراد الكبير بدون الحاجه او بدون
النظر الى قطاع التصنيع والتصدير الحلم
العربي والسوق عربي واحده ان واحد واحد
يحط مثال السعوديه